I'm deeply moved and inspired by Michael
and that's because of the diversity of
his performance on screen
is
difficult and unusual subject matter and
he transports it to the big screen in a
way that we've never seen before
Diane Warren to me is undeniably one of
the most important songwriters of all
time she's been there for a lot of major
moments in people's lives
unique ability to choose just the right
words and create the most beautiful
Melody to bring out the emotion of a
movie She's royalty to me the work of
usan policy means so much to me she's a
Trailblazer in the truest sense of the
word and I'm sure there were many times
that she felt alone but she wasn't
because there were girls like me falling
behind her looking at her as the beacon
of light ozone's work really showcases
this idea that not only are we willing
to Showcase stories of underrepresented
groups but we are also willing to talk
about these Topics in society that are
willing to progress us forward so thank
you so much for your work ozone you
really deserved it this is a very much
deserved award and I
say congratulations Diane it is my honor
to congratulate you Michael J fox